hello there it's ps+ time again the
mid-mon update that adds a bunch of
games to the extra premium and Deluxe
tiers of ps+ all the games You' SE in
today's video are also download from
October the 17th and I reckon you're
going to be happy with this month let's
do this first of your extra games is
Gotham Knights an action game in which
Batman is no more and four other
characters step up to fill the void he
left behind Nightwing red hood Batgirl
and Robin each character has their own
move set their own gadgets and their own
way to Traverse the open world during
daylight hours our new heroes are found
at the belfree which acts as a home base
and allows conversations and
investigations to be triggered before
switching to nighttime and going out on
parole in Gotham the standard game can
be played in online co-op with a friend
which really adds to the experience and
a four-player game mode which is like a
wave based mission is available at the
end game reviewers found Gotham Knights
to be quite mediocre with the highest
score I could find a seven there are
some technical issues too running at 30
frames a second seem to be quite
unacceptable for quite a lot of gamers
in my opinion when ps+ extra was
announced this is the type of game I
thought was perfect for it the highest
rated game of the month is Disco elisium
the Final Cut boasting many nines and
Perfect 10 out of 10 scores disco
elisium is a role playing game which
combines detective sleuthing with a
twisting plot filled with a depth of
choice many games only dream of every
line is voiced including your own
character in a monologue even in a room
all alone you're not alone dialogue
trees play the biggest part in Disco
elisium with many tabletop RPG moments
here which will change the story
Direction in many ways don't let the art
style put you off this is one of the
greatest games ever made it's such a big
deal a TV show is going to be made of
disco elisium if you enjoy narrative and
choice in your video games you have to
play this so it's Halloween season and
Playstation have added a bunch of
suspense survival outings for you and
your adult diapers alien isolation is
almost a decade old and is still
considered by many the greatest alien
game ever made armed with a heartbeat
sensor we must navigate our ship and
complete tasks we play the entire game
Through The Eyes of Amanda Ripley who's
Ellen's daughter fighting the alien is
almost always the wrong idea we must
instead find places to hide away and
stay as silent as possible as one wrong
move could be the end for you craftable
weapons do add a little more equality to
affairs with Molotov flamethrowers and
simple noise makers to redirect the
milon away average review score 8 out of
10 created in the same mold is outlast 2
a game in which we have no means to
fight and must run hide and hope not to
be found Outlast 2 has us using a night
vision camcorder that constantly runs
out of batteries it's so frustrating but
it absolutely adds to the tension and
the suspense of the game this Outlast
game deals with the horror fantasy
tropes of witches and the undead while
weaving a story which is quite easy to
miss to be honest so be sure to pay
attention during the school scenes okay
oh and jump scares are plentiful here
not for the faint-hearted average score
7.5 out of 10 the next game is Dead
Island definitive collection on the PS4
this one is much more of a standard
action game than anything to really fear
mainly built around melee combat against
the undead where earning XP levels your
character and their abilities and
there's a constant flow of this through
the game we play as one of four
survivors ranging from a police officer
to an American football player from
there it's basically a free for all as
you lay waste to hundreds and thousands
of the zombie horde nothing
groundbreaking in terms of gameplay but
a great time all the same average score
7 out of 10 another Halloween game the
dark pictures Anthology House Of Ashes
from back in 2021 this one is an
interactive story in which we make
decisions for the cast and watch where
it takes them House Of Ashes doesn't hit
the same Heights as until dawn but has
similar options including Perma death
for your fallen protagonists and
multiple endings to find adding military
characters to a survival setting does
add a different dimension to things
which should keep you gripped for the
entirety of the story if you're a fan of
films like saw House Of Ashes will suit
you well some characters are brilliantly
written and performed and some are a
walking train wreck which may lead you
to make some decisions based on
likeability hasashi meta score 75 out of
100 Souls born fans the next one is for
you take a look at eldest souls wow
that's close to copyright a Souls like
game with a retro art style set during a
time when human ity decided to overthrow
the gods those pesky deities have now
Unleashed Devastation upon this world
and Mankind is fading our job is to take
down those Supreme Beings which grants
us new abilities constantly evolving our
play style the variety of combat options
is described as incredibly satisfying
leading to eldest souls receiving a
handful of eight out of 10 scores next
guns lots of guns this is gun grave Gore
a 13-hour Massacre taking down thousands
upon thousands of monsters and these
monsters are here because of a plague
controlled by a Mafia Family expect an
elite storyline here your entire job is
to take them out all of them and we
carry around a coffin with us cool
there's an interesting beats mechanic
which is essentially a combo meter which
is tricky to manage and maintain
reviewers say this is very me or five
out of 10 if you prefer far changing
tides is a sailing based puzzle game set
on the open Waves sidescrolling through
a post-apocalyptic World there is no
fighting in Far instead it's more about
management of your ship and navigating
to find resources then once all the
above ground Shenanigans are over your
ship morphs into a submarine and there's
more to do Under The Waves the PS5
version of far changing tides is rated
at 81% on Metacritic another game
without a fixation on violence is Roki a
pointand click adventure set in the
wilderness as we play a young girl
trying to find her bro littered with
puzzles that slowly evolve and
eventually need more than one character
to solve hidden paths can lead to long
for forgotten worlds containing beasts
and creatures of Legend I've already
said too much let's move on currently at
82 on Metacritic do you remember the
space flight Sim Elite dangerous well
it's still alive and kicking and now
it's on ps+ extra the ever evolving
space role playing game can be
approached in many ways whether that's
shooting everything in sight or becoming
a Smuggler of goods or both if you're
playing a hand solo type exploration is
the main draw to Elite dangerous as
later additions added firstperson
shooting and Planet walking to the space
combat wait is this here because we
didn't get Starfield as always games are
leaving the catalog 16 this time around
and there are some big hitters on their
way out on October 17th you will be
losing the Fantastic Far Cry 4 and its
less impressive brother Far Cry 5 the
Yakuza remasters of three four and five
are all going the perfect Halloween game
is leaving before Halloween bye-bye the
Quarry and the brilliant inside and
limbo are going too other games on their
way out are the medium the crew Shinobi
Strikers clouds and sheep 2 Aster breed
tle gunvault burst and Travis Scott's
favorite game Goosebumps he plays it
every time on October 17th those 16
games will become locked okay over to
PlayStation premium also called
PlayStation Deluxe and things are
changing thanks to Sony's new core app
PlayStation Plus subscribers can now
stream hundreds of movies with a promise
that the selection will continuously
update there's too many to cover right
now but in future I'll shout out when a
highly rated movie is added to the
collection now to the games themselves
coming to your PS4 and PS5 there are
three PSP titles Tekken 6 ape Academy
escape and soulcaliber broken Destiny
which I believe is the one that had
kattos in and finally an OG PlayStation
game IG finals so what do you think to
the month are you playing anything scary
this time around I'm Adam you're awesome
thanks for sticking around I'll see you
next
time